well your mail could take longer to
reach you under a new plan that takes
effect today the postmaster general is
slowing down some deliveries and raising
prices he wants to balance the postal
service budget as errol barnett reports
critics say it will cause serious damage
i've been coming up here every week
asking where's my mail marissa taylor
relies on the post office to deliver her
paychecks that she uses to take care of
her two siblings with special needs they
keep giving me the same answer which is
oh you have a new driver it'll be out
today you don't get mail that day taylor
went without mail for days over the
summer and new changes from the u.s
postal service mean more delays could be
in her future in march postmaster
general lewis to joy announced a new
10-year plan that promises to cut debt
and modernize the agency we haven't been
funded in 10 years you can't pass any
legislation can't pass any legislation
that helps i can just finish this point
but it comes at a cost almost 40 percent
of first-class mail could take up to
five days to arrive instead of up to
three days and sending holiday cheer
will be pricier as well with postage
rates increasing up to five dollars more
per package until december 26th i see a
bright future ahead for the postal
service the joy has been a controversial
head of the postal service since june of
2020. before the election the former
businessman and top gop donor made
changes to the service including
removing mailboxes
many rallied nationwide against what
they saw as voter suppression
and earlier this year 21 state attorneys
general asked the postal regulatory
commission to reject the new plan saying
it could disproportionately impact
elderly and rural residents as well as
individuals with disabilities these cuts
plain and simple are illegal
and we should also highlight there are
so many americans who rely on this
service for the delivery of their
medicine cbs news spoke with one man
who's already experienced delays
receiving his heart and behavioral
medications he's now concerned that will
happen more often if you're like him the
advice is send your mail a few days
early or tony consider another service
sad but true all right errol thank you
very much